monde je n'appuie pas je descends
j'appuie vous voyez c'est ancien
professeur et cette animatrice simule un
cours d'écriture au début du 20e siècle
lire écrire compter étaient les
principaux enseignements dispensés
mais la journée commençait par un tout
autre type d'apprentissage on vérifier
la propreté beaucoup de l'hygiène
enfin parce que les enfants n'aiment pas
prendre de douche et où donc souvent
fallait faire se laver les mains
vérifier qu'il n'y avait pas de pouls
donc en général c'était premières dix
minutes après morales aux côtés des
plumes en criée et objets centenaire des
fusils factice accroché au mur
à la fin du 19e siècle les gars on
apprenait dans des bataillons scolaire à
se battre pour récupérer l'alsace et la
lorraine aux allemands des sous officier
à la retraite étaient leurs instructeurs
militaires et leurs appreniez à aux
pôles et le fusil et a tiré en tout
l'association des amis du musée a
rassemblé plus de dix mille objets qui
couvrent une période allant des années
1880 à 1975
mais c'est avant tout l'esprit de jules
ferry qui est ici mise en avant
c'est à dire l'école censé offrir
l'égalité des chances à tous les enfants
l'école gratuite laïque et obligatoire
l'obligation c'était empêcher que les
enfants n'aillent au fond des mines
travailler et dès l'âge de 9 ans c'était
empêcher que mes enfants entre
guillemets une soirée conditionné pour
tous les travaux des champs au delà de
conserver le patrimoine de l'école le
musée de chartres prépare pour la
nouvelle saison des animations
audiovisuelles avec les ancêtres du
rétroprojecteur